February 2019 will see a ton of new
Netflix content with exciting new
releases in every major genre we've
rounded up the best of the best to
showcase everything greats coming to
Netflix in February 20 1934 ingest a new
black produced and stars in Russian doll
a serious about a woman forced to relive
the night of a big party over and over
again an experience which is always
rudely interrupted by her death forget
the obvious similarity to happy deathday
the always entertaining Leone told The
Hollywood Reporter it's an autobiography
wrapped in a mind-bending concept I'm
100% in there and most definitely the
architect of the whole thing the show
not only sports a deadpan sense of humor
but has the potential to get very
interesting very quickly and the first
season drops on February 1st the third
feature from Mike roller director Dan
Gilroy reunites him with the amazing
films lead actors Jake Gyllenhaal and
Rene Russo along with John Malkovich and
Toni Collette it's the story of a SOHO
art gallery owner and a vicious critic
who come into possession of the works of
an artist whose recent death is shrouded
in mystery and they soon which they
hadn't
connected to his art
[Applause]
the flicks insane trailer promises a
mind-bending ride a committed
performance from Gyllenhaal and a bunch
of profoundly creepy imagery
this is Gilroy's first foray into flats
al-tohra and you can give it a watch on
February 1st the finished detective
series border town was picked up for
international distribution by Netflix
after its debut season which went on to
strike a chord with streaming audiences
with his dark compelling story telling
fans of shows like The Killing and true
detective will find a border town to be
a treat on the first episode of season 1
aired on finished television it was
watched by over a million viewers if you
haven't checked out the first batch of
episodes you may want to catch up before
season 2 drops on February 2nd
screenwriter Terrell Alvin McCraney
picked up an Oscar for Co script in the
2016 Best Picture winner moon lights his
next trick he's giving us high-flying
bird a fictionalized account of the
efforts of a sports agent the sow visa
careers of his clients on the wake of
the real-life 2011 NBA lockout oh and in
the director's chair is Steven
Soderbergh whose recent successes
include Logan lucky and a psychological
thriller insane the sports drama a
scoring big tongue with critics you can
give it a shot when it premieres On
February 8th the break is a Belgian
series which follows the attempt of a
veteran police detective to escape from
his demons by returning to his peaceful
relatively murder free home town but
things take a turn for the worse when a
body is discovered leading our
protagonist down a sinister path the
first season was well received by
critics who appreciated its bleak
cinematography and snappy well-written
dialogue then a Waris drama makes its
return with season two on February 9th
Daily Show veteran Hasan Minhaj made a
splash with the first season of it's
insightful political comedy series
Patriot Act in which he explores topics
relevant to today's society through the
filter of his unique comedic Sensibility
each episode focuses on a single topic
which Minaj delves into through a
combination of stand-up interviews and
on location segments Minaj is cutting
yet thoughtful brand of political humor
is perhaps something we can all use more
of right now and season Tim of Patriot
Act will give us that when it drops On
February 10th the breaker opera's is a
comedy film from New Zealand with thor
ragnarok director Taika Waititi involved
as an executive producer
this world of amazement here through
this door
Australia Sammy and Jackie Van Beek
directors of the breaker operas came
into white tt's orbit when they appeared
as actors in his features what we do in
the shadows and eagle versus shark in
addition to directing the pair also star
a cynical friends who go into business
breaking up couples for profits what the
film scored with critics when it made
the festival rounds and it will likely
score with you when it hits the small
screen on February 15th based on a Dark
Horse comic book series created by
Gerard Way the original series the
Umbrella Academy follows a group of
children with otherworldly powers who
are all born simultaneously on the same
day in 1989 brought together in their
teen years by a mysterious billionaire
they all regroup 17 years later upon
their benefactors death in an attempt to
get to the bottom of the events
surrounding his passing get ready for
super-powered intrigue when the first
season drops on February 15th this
violent period peas from Korea explores
the rise of a petty crook from Busan who
ups his game by diving into the Asian
narcotics trade of the 1970s eventually
he becomes you guessed it a drug gang
struggling to hold his place atop his
organization while pouring a steady
stream of contraband into Japan and
keeping up a front as a benevolent
community leader look for it on February
21st paddled son is a sophomore feature
from director Alex layman and stars
co-writer Mark Duplass alongside Ray
Romano as Odd Couple neighbors who
develop an unlikely friendship their
bond is quickly put to the test however
when one of them receives a terminal
cancer diagnosis the flick absolutely
wild critics on the festival circuit
with Romano's performance in particular
being singled out for praise
you know drinking a year you'll
definitely want to check out paddled
some when it makes it streaming debut on
February 22nd there's more than meets
the eye to the French drama Paris's us
the story of a young woman who returns
to a home city the trailer promises a
blurring of the lines between fantasy
and reality as the heroine begins to
draw parallels between a traumatic
recent past and events and the world at
large so now that everything is possible
even if this life may be just a dream
the Kickstarter funded project was shot
between 2014 and 2017 before being
picked up by Netflix Paris has not been
resting easy as of late and this
incorporates some real-world tension
into its rather trippy narrative you can
check it out on February 22nd
Saburo is a gritty Italian crime series
centered on a seaside town near Rome
which various interested parties have
designs on turning into a gambling
resorts coming into conflict with each
other over these plans are a prominent
Roman family a slew of corrupt
politicians a Catholic Church and the
Mafia the series first season drew
favorable comparisons with the wire and
was widely praised for its stark tone
and thriller asked pacing profane war
and violence it's being called the kind
of show that grabs your attention and
doesn't let go perfect for binge
watching season 2 premieres on February
22nd there are a few choice selections
for thriller fans in February most
notably the first installment of the
long-running final destination series
that arrives with the entirety of the
jaws franchise from Steven Spielberg's
benchmark setting original to jaws the
revenge a feature that regularly winds
up in discussion of the worst films of
all time
those show up on the first alongside a
number of beloved comedies starting this
month look for the warm Hugh Grant
vehicle about a boy and the first three
American Pie movies later in the month
Steve Carell's breakout film the 40 year
old virgin arrives in the sixteenth
followed by the comedy-drama Our Idiot
Brother on the 26th only a pair of new
drama rings are making their way to
Netflix this month but they're both well
worth a watch 2016 the edge of seventeen
features burgeoning star Hailee
Steinfeld in a thoughtful coming-of-age
drama and drops on the 1st and on the
sick look for 2009 the soloist starring
Robert Downey jr. as a newspaper
columnist who becomes unlikely friends
with a blind violinist played by Jamie
Foxx finally Netflix is premiering three
new original comedy specials in February
on the fifth Ray Romano returns to New
York's famed Comedy Cellar after 23
years to deliver a new stand-up set and
right here around the corner Kevin Hart
examines the contributions of African
Americans through his uniquely cracked
lens in a new special available on the
8th and the Alerus ken Jeong delivers a
Valentine's Day set of silliness and his
first Netflix special on the 14th can't
do that check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Applause]